[Music]
hey you guys it's monday
yep yep yeah i didn't see this movie you
saw part of it saw parts of it well what
ended up happening was that like i said
we were kind of thinking about going and
seeing the new james wan movie malignant
last night but then by the time we were
done with the live stream and i had a
couple other things to do and i'm just
like man we were just like too worn out
so i said okay so what we're going to do
so this review might be a little bit
short sir because we got to leave yeah
because we're going to go see malignant
and it starts at 4 15
which means that we'd have to leave here
at like 3 45 or something like that
but like i said this is a newer movie
this is lights out from 2016 and it's
really weird i didn't know but
there's a little connection james wan
was also a producer on this movie uh
which i didn't know going in and it also
has a small part by which somebody just
pointed out earlier by maria bello who
was also in secret window which we did
on the movie retrospective last week and
see it's all connected man
synchronicities all over the place i
totally didn't like now why like i
didn't do that on purpose like by any
stretch of the imagination also i should
say too that
this is the feature-length debut film
of david f sandberg who would later go
on to direct annabelle creation which eh
but also he went on to direct shazam so
you know what i mean so this was his
first uh full-length movie now i had
been wanting to see this for a really
long time because i don't know if you
guys remember but back in 2013
there was a short
uh called lights out
and uh which david f sandberg made him
and his wife lada lawson who was also in
that short
made this uh movie i think it was only
two or three minutes long to be honest
with you um but they made it for a
competition but it didn't win but it was
really really good like the short was
really good and it went viral i remember
seeing it like back then everybody was
talking about it's like watch this short
it's so good and it was like really
really good so
because it went viral um he got
contacted by a bunch of like movie
producers it's like hey
maybe you can make like a full-length
movie out of this so he did finally get
around to doing that in 2016 where he
kind of like expanded the uh the lore of
the short because the short film is
basically just like like i said it's
like three minutes long so they really
had a lot of backstory to do
so what you got with this
it's basically about um okay
so the the monster ghost whatever it is
i'll kind of get into that a little in a
little bit um is one of those ones it's
kind of like the original short where
you can only see it when the lights are
out like the lights are out and like you
just see like the silhouette but then
when you turn the lights on it's gone
you know what i'm saying because it's it
can't like survive in the light or
whatever so
so we have that now what ends up
happening there's this family and it's a
mom and she's um got some issues and she
has a son
and the dad has died the dad has
actually been killed by the
you know the ghost monster thing at the
very beginning like in the cold open
and then we're kind of going to like a
little bit later where the mom is kind
of like having all kind of problems with
i think she's like a manic depressive or
what something like they're bipolar or
something like that she's on like some
kind of medication and she also has a
son and then she has a daughter
um that's like by another marriage or
something and then but that she's older
and she like lives by herself like with
a boyfriend
now at the beginning i actually really
liked the setup of this like i said the
cold open is very good where the dad of
the family like is at work he works in a
mannequin factory of all things uh it
looks like i guess it's a mannequin
factory i'm not really sure what it is
they have mannequin factories i don't
know if it was a mannequin factory or if
it was just like it looked like a
factory i don't know if they were making
mannequins or if they were just like
making clothes and they had mannequins
there i couldn't really tell it's not
important i don't think the united
states has mannequin factories
well someone's got to make them
let's be china it's funny because every
time i see like i just randomly kind of
think about this sometimes it's like
every time you steal it's just like this
[ __ ]
useless like little you know
gadget or dude ad or whatever i'm just
kind of like somewhere in the world
there's a factory that makes nothing but
those probably yeah or they probably
make other things too but you'd lose
your shirt making like only that one
specific like very specific thing but
yeah so at the beginning there's um
kind of like like i said just a few
minutes scene where they're setting up
like the monster and everything and the
dad gets killed and then they uh kind of
cut back to like the main characters
um one thing i did like about this like
i said this the setup of it i thought
was kind of cool because it's almost
kind of like you know how in a lot of
horror movies like this
you have um
the kid having like an imaginary friend
and oh [ __ ] it turns out that it's a
real ghost
um they have that but i like that the
mom has the imaginary friend and not the
kid and and also the friend's not
imaginary because the friend is actually
does actually exist but what ends up
happening is like the little kid he's
getting like kind of freaked out and he
can't sleep
in his house right because um you know
every time the light goes out here it's
like scratching or he sees like this
creepy [ __ ] uh you know this creepy
silhouette or whatever in the shadows
and then he has to sleep with all the
lights on so he's been like staying
awake and stuff and he'll like creep
down the [ __ ] hall and like say hey
mom what's up and she's like talking to
somebody in her closet
you know what i mean and uh so he's like
uh you know hey mom what are you doing
nothing i'm just talking to my friend
who's in the closet you know what i mean
so it's like it's it's so that's like a
really good like setup
so the kid because he's not getting any
sleep at home because of this like weird
situation um he's like falling asleep at
school so you know he has to go to the
nurse and then you know it's happened a
bunch of times so they call cps and then
they have to go and i guess cps is kind
of familiar with this whole like uh
scenario because
they're like hey your mom's on her
medication as long as she's on the
medication like she's allowed to like
have the kid and everything but they
keep calling the mom and she won't
answer for whatever reason so they end
up having to call the sister who's kind
of like a strange she's grown up like i
said 18 or 19. so she actually she's
actually his half sister i suppose but
she comes and gets him and he starts
talking about
you know our mom is like talking to
somebody in the closet just talking to
diana and the the sisters but is
basically like oh um yeah i remember
that [ __ ] from when i was growing up
like it was a ghosty monstery type of
situation in the house so she does like
a bunch of research and finds out like
who this ghost is uh and what the hell
is going on so as i said this is kind of
like it's pg-13 okay which
it can work i have seen seen some good
pg-13 uh you know horror movies
um this one was kind of like middle of
the road you know what i mean it just
seemed like one of those
it was better than
something like
like comparable like the bye-bye man
which i hated so much that for whatever
reason i just turned it off um so it was
a lot better than that
uh but it's not like super great or
super memorable either it's like it's
pretty short it's only like 80
minutes 82 minutes something like that
and it actually got a big theatrical
release and it made like a bunch of
money it made enough money that they um
almost immediately were like yeah we
need to make a sequel to that [ __ ]
so it did really well i don't know if
they're gonna make one or not but they
did actually like put one into
production like the week or two after
this one open they were like yeah we
need to make another one
so
um
the thing i okay so i liked like a lot
of the acting i liked the concept i
liked a lot of the um particularly like
the third act where they were shooting
uh you know where the house went dark
and they were like looking for sources
of light and the whole thing about the
the uh the black light and you know how
you can still see the ghosts and
everything like that um i liked all that
kind of stuff like the character [ __ ]
was good um you know the like i said the
silhouette of the ghost was creepy it
didn't need a lot of gore
or anything because it just had like
some nice creepy moments to it but one
thing i will say is that
one i didn't really like
um
the backstory
like i said i don't want to really want
to spoil it because this movie's not
that old but i didn't really like the
backstory they came up with for diana
who's like the monster also i didn't
really get a good sense of
because they're acting like she's a
ghost but then they're also acting like
she's a physical because she was alive
at some point and she is dead
but
then they keep saying well she's not a
ghost i'm like well i don't know what
she's just some kind of like
supernatural being type of thing but she
can do like physical [ __ ]
another thing that i didn't like and i
don't know why they made this decision
the thing that
i think
everybody loved about the short film
that went viral back in 2013
was the look of that ghost i mean the
face that was what i remember for
because i was like [ __ ]
it was like a really good because you
only got to look you only got a look of
it for like a second or two but it was
it just burned into your memory like the
look of it was just so awesome
so i don't know why they redesigned
maybe they i mean i get why maybe they
did because they were just kind of like
well everyone's seen that because it you
know even stills of it like made the
rounds because it was so [ __ ] creepy
looking and they're like well everyone's
seen that so we want to make her look
different
which fair enough
but when you see her she doesn't look
all that distinctive i felt like the one
in the short looked really distinctive
and it really like stood out um and a
lot of people remembered it like i said
you know it was it went memes there was
memes about it everything like that and
um the one in the movie just looks kind
of like generic it looks like a a bunch
of
creepy
lady ghosts in those type of movies
so i thought that was um
just kind of a weird i mean if you you
can change the look fine but it's like i
wish they would have made it look more
impactful like when you actually did
seer
um like the first one was even if they
had wanted to do something different
so i don't know why they went with that
uh with that look but whatever um
another thing too is that
i was actually not uh i didn't see that
end coming this is actually had a real
kind of downer ending
which
i i was actually i was startled by it
and that i was kind of like oh that was
kind of ballsy i like that they ended it
like that
and they didn't do that whole oh maybe
she's not dead you know what i mean i
mean they did a tiny bit of that but it
wasn't like anything big deal
but i mean i i just liked the way they
just like really had a really impactful
ending i thought some people didn't like
it because
i can't really say why they didn't like
it because it'll spoil it
but um
some people were kind of upset by it but
i don't know i liked that they ended it
like that because i thought it was
ballsy i didn't think they would go that
far
with the ending of it but it is like
kind of a bummer ending
but i don't know overall like i said
this was you know it was a pretty solid
flick like i said it's just kind of like
one of those friday night pizza and beer
you just want to watch like a scary
movie that has like some creepy [ __ ] in
it but you don't have to like think
about it too hard you know what i mean
it's one of those like i said it's not
i've seen a lot like this
and they're enjoyable
but they're not memorable right like
sometimes i'll like sometimes i'll
scroll through like netflix or something
like that i saw this on hulu it might
also be on netflix i'm not sure but i
watched it on hulu um
i you know sometimes i'll scroll through
and i'll see like the cards for it and
then i'll be like did i watch that
because sometimes i can't remember like
ones that i saw or not because i and i
remember like i enjoyed it at the time
but it's like i can't remember if you
asked me to talk about it now i wouldn't
remember saying a single thing all those
conjuring universe movies are like that
to me they're they're kind of not
memorable they're okay they're enjoyable
and honestly even the first conjuring
movie the first conjuring movie
obviously was the best one um and even
that one even um
even though a lot of people talk about
how that was like a great horror but
which i can see that and like if you do
think that it's like i'm not like
[ __ ] on you or anything but
i i watched it and i liked it but i
didn't see
what was super super special about it
you know what i'm saying remember we saw
a lot okay you don't know what i
remember the most about those movies uh
la llorona remember that one la la rona
la rona ronas i was called that was a
good one the way that thing looked was
[ __ ] pretty
freaky you know waves of people yeah
remember how they had like the
17 or 18 year old hispanic kid must have
weighed about a buck 25 in the in the
audience who was just losing it and then
trying to play it off like he wasn't
scared
yeah that that kid having that kid there
[ __ ] made that movie with it it
really did yeah the [ __ ]
would have [ __ ] laughed his ass off
cause he was a teenager and he's there
with his boys and he had all these
[ __ ] girls and [ __ ] with him and he's
going
to scream
like a [ __ ] woman like on four
[ __ ] occasions but then it was over
he's like oh no i'm scared i'm not
scared
sorry somebody just like pinched my ass
yeah he tried to play it off every
[ __ ] time man
that's honestly one of the that's
honestly one of the best things about
seeing horror movies
i don't normally like seeing it depends
on what kind of movie it is i don't
normally like seeing movies with other
people ever
but um he had a real thick accent and
everything [ __ ] hurt
louis hernandez [ __ ] thought that
[ __ ] was funny man i think you
might have been cuban or something
it's hard to say no probably not central
america i just feel like well there's a
whole thing too oh look um
somebody looked up and said uh i looked
it up the us does make mannequins they
do manx u.s manix okay man x like an
annex but never heard of it there's usa
in new york okay
i knew somebody had to make it goddamn
it i just didn't know if they made any
in this country but i was just so i
don't know i just thought it was funny
like the very beginning it's like
mannequin factory let's get some tourist
trap vibes going in there because
mannequins are always scary i don't care
well because there were like there was
some [ __ ] with mannequins at the end too
where
yeah and um
yeah they also said problem was it was
overwritten yeah that's that's the only
thing i felt like the the backstory was
like a little too complicated
but like i said overall for this type of
movie it was actually really enjoyable
and i thought like some of the imagery
was really good i just wish that they
had made
diana the ghost monster
person i wish they had made her more
look more like the one from the short
because the one from the short was
horrifying like the face was horrifying
and um it was just really well done and
it looked really distinctive like i said
this one just didn't look i can't even
really remember what she looked like to
be honest with you like what i'm
thinking about it now it was just like a
generic scary
like conjuring universe ghost monster it
looked a little bit like la yorona's
face actually maybe now that i'm
thinking about it or maybe i'm just
mixing them all together hugo said that
uh that the la you're on a [ __ ] movie
was nothing like that it wasn't no
um
i'd never heard of i've heard of the
legend but i don't know any of those
legends but the way it looked it i
thought it looked good
it was pretty cool looking i mean i
don't remember a lot about that movie
would kind of appear slowly and [ __ ] and
just having that kid he must he probably
hadn't been 15 or 16. he was [ __ ]
losing it
[ __ ] losing it and then trying to
play it off
like like he like he wasn't scared and
everything was just [ __ ] funny i
always kind of wonder about that too
because sometimes we don't like i said
if we go see horror movies in a theater
um usually usually we go to movies like
in the afternoon and stuff like that
because it's not as crowded on the few
occasions that i've been at night when
it was like really full it's like you
always get these big groups of teenagers
yeah that's what it was and it's stupid
because the teenagers will go see the
[ __ ] because like oh it's a horror
movie it's friday night or whatever and
they don't have anything better to do so
they go out and see a horror movie and
then they either
don't watch it they just sit there
looking at their phone the whole time or
they just make fun of it the whole time
and make like a lot of noise yeah or
they'll do it or they just like
overreact to everything or they just
like laugh at everything which is like i
don't know i just wish people would shut
up in general but yeah
i know
i wasn't like that one actually on the
la yorona one
i i think it was pretty quiet it was
just him
yeah because well and he was sitting
like in the same row as us yeah no it
was i was out of this a couple couple oh
okay and he was [ __ ] losing i was
thinking of a different time yeah he was
[ __ ] losing it and he was probably
with about six or seven other teenagers
half of them were girls they were if
there was a lot of a lot of hispanics in
the in to see it that night it was on a
weekend at night but second saturday or
friday night yeah i think we actually
did go to the right so
maybe they were mexican i don't know
he had a strong accent but you know
hispanic accent you know central
american accent could be anything you
know
spanish if your primary spanish speaker
you're going to have
a little bit of an accent but even a
secondary
you know [ __ ] guys from california
have a slight accent um new mexico too
even though they might not even speak
spanish or just a little bit they still
have a span they still have a spanish
accent but uh he was [ __ ] losing it
and i was [ __ ] thinking i just
thought that [ __ ] was [ __ ] funny i
could kind of
put myself in his shoes you know what i
mean what of what it would have been
like if i was a little bit younger i was
so hardened to [ __ ]
horrible it's like we're old and we've
seen everything so it's just kind of
like i'm like oh you're doing a thing
like that other movie yeah you know what
i mean and i think what was getting him
is he's getting sucked in by the sound
effects
because remember [ __ ] the sound would
come in and it was really
like if you were to see the same thing
and didn't have any if it didn't have a
sound soundtrack with it it wouldn't
have affected you but that sounded
effect that that's the soundtrack is
what's really getting you
or tries to well yeah like i said i mean
honestly if you want to see a horror
movie be completely drained of all it
scares and i've said this before just
watch it with the sound down yeah and it
is not scary at all nope and uh that's
so with [ __ ] when you get to be me and
jenny's age and you know all these
tricks
i can tell when something's coming most
of the time just on what the with the
sound well and particularly the kind of
not so much the first conjuring like i
said but the movies that came in the
wake of that yeah there's this whole
other you know i know we have kind of
what we call like the artisan horror
films you know like mid-summer and stuff
like ariastor is doing and everything um
but then you also have these just kind
of like crowd pleaser popcorn horror
movies which is fine um and some of
those are actually pretty good like i
said this one kind of falls the one i'm
talking about
when i was talking about earlier lights
out just kind of uh goes along with that
too and it's like not everything has to
be you know the shining ever not
everything has to be a masterpiece
sometimes it can just be like a fun
thing to watch like you know on
halloween or whenever
and but the thing about it is that it's
so
formulaic these ones particularly you
know after james wan got
you know popular with the conjuring
universe all of the movies that kind of
ripped that off a little bit i don't
want to say they ripped that off
specifically because that's been going
on forever but they always you know when
the jump scare is going to come because
everything goes quiet it's like all the
noise goes like oh i'm creeping down the
hall and everything goes super super
silent and there's like blah you know
like the cat jumps out of the closet or
whatever it's just like with a big like
musical sting and it's just kind of like
how many times can you do that i can't
remember what movie it was that i saw
not too long ago but oh [ __ ] man i don't
think it was one of the conjuring movies
but it was something kind of like that a
b squad one and um it's it it did that
so many times that it just became like
humorous
now hernandez says every
mexican-american kid that's been to
mexico swears they've seen la llorona
it could be that
it's
probably what it is i really hadn't
considered that
the story was probably more a lot more
culturally relevant to him than it was
to the average person yeah he had an
accent
it was pretty strong he might have just
been mexican okay not may not have been
mexican-american but he did speak
english he was
maybe he was first generation you know
maybe his parents brought him here
and he was [ __ ] losing it though as
as if la llorona was a reality
and so i think what it was there might
have been some pr some build up
some build up before he even saw this
thing you know some cultural buildup
yeah so
you know that probably helped him
[ __ ] get scared
maybe i kind of feel like um i don't
really know but maybe the whole la
lloreno legend
was not real
well known was not widely known in the
united states i i knew of it from when i
was a kid because i have one i had one
of those big like creepy unsolved
mysteries of the world and it talked
about the la you're on a legend in there
like and that was back in the 70s i had
heard of it but i didn't know what it
was until then yeah so i had read about
it when i was a kid
um so but i don't know if like um people
like if
wider america was more
was real like familiar with that legend
no they weren't and so i guess it's not
going to be as scary to somebody who
didn't grow up with
those stories be like imagine you're
going to see a bigfoot movie you don't
know who bigfoot is
you don't even know what that is yeah
you know i mean if you're a north
american you know what bigfoot is
you know what loch ness monster is
so you don't really need you've already
got something there
that you can scare somebody with you're
not inventing something out of whole
cloth although i feel like stuff like
bigfoot and loch ness monster and stuff
is maybe like less culturally based
because everybody every country every
culture has something like that even if
it's not called the same thing yeah at
least you know everybody's got lake
monsters everybody's got wild men of the
forest everybody's got even if they're
called something different it's like
essentially the same all right the thing
that would be uniquely american would be
amityville
yeah okay if you grew up thinking that
amityville really happened
which i kind of thought it did for a
while until i got older i think
everybody did to research it more i
remember reading that book when i was a
kid that was the one by jay anthony
amityville was just as just as
historical as bloodsport
just as historically blessed
at the end it told you how many [ __ ]
people he defeated and killed in a ring
of course give you his fighting style
they just didn't tell you that they were
all imaginary people
wait a minute this is a real story this
is a true story oh man it adds a whole
or there were little stick people that
had drawn on a piece of paper oh man it
was like smash smash back in the 80s
we'd give a [ __ ] trent in michigan
and [ __ ]
at the end of blood sport we're like
whoa mine's blown man that really
happened we just didn't watch that dude
the badass well it really happened yeah
and of course that happened yeah you
didn't know that happened how
everybody's lied to each other yeah that
happened read it in black belt magazine
of course it happened you know they
printed it
it's true yeah how much it costs to
print something on paper
[Laughter]
it was a it was a simpler time
[Laughter]
well like i said you can't you know you
can't be too everything a lot of people
believed that amityville [ __ ] too yeah
like back in the day
yeah
um
no
i haven't even worked it
no sorry
no i don't think so either there's there
were too many things surrounded
too many
too many different stories surrounding
it that that it was a it was a it was a
it was a hoax to make money
the lutz has hoaxed it with a lawyer
beowulf 18 says and everyone knows what
zombies are except for on screen in
movies where they've never heard of them
see that's kind of one thing that really
bothers me about horror movies i mean i
guess i can understand it like in older
horror movies you know like in the old
hammer ones where it's like always
somebody's like oh they have two holes
in their neck and they're drained of
blood i wonder what could be going on
and then somebody has to come in and
explain like what a vampire's with the
big you know tomes and everything
but it's like i feel like nobody has to
do that anymore because look everybody
knows and can we not like in the movie
universe it kind of takes me out of it
when everyone's pretending that they
don't know exactly because in real life
if a zombie apocalypse started that's
exactly what everyone would call it a
zombie apocalypse
so uh louie's confirming my suspicions
he says louis said that yeah the la
llorona is our boogeyman yeah and then
he goes tom you're 100 percent right we
were told about la llorona as we were
little kids yeah so the reason why he's
freaking out is that he was totally
primed yeah in his mind since childhood
he feared that something like la yorono
did exist maybe a part of him believed
that it did exist so seeing it on the
screen blew his [ __ ] mind and he
tried to play it off
no the irrational side of him was taken
over but that's cool because i kind of
feel like the ideal horror audience like
i said i don't you know and becoming for
me it's like somebody i really really
like horror movies but i'm older and
i've seen a lot of them so it's like
nothing it takes a lot to like shock me
or surprise me or scare me or anything
like that like sometimes it still does
but it takes a lot or something
different but i think the best way to go
into horror movies don't go into horror
movies this isn't going to be scary
this is stupid and i just think that's a
dumb it was like well then don't watch
it yeah it's like just kind of like let
yourself get sucked into the story
that's the whole point of a horror movie
it's supposed to like creep you out it's
supposed to scare you just let it do
that all right hernandez what got me
the way it got that kid
on on a say an anglo-cultural level was
that mid-summer
yeah
[Laughter]
and
and like maybe the original wicker man
because
you're seeing
european caucasian culture
at like a
primitive magical thinking
level in other words it'd be like you're
taking white people back to that was
like our version of the aztec level
you know yeah exactly the same thing so
that you see you can [ __ ] with the
mexicans mind by doing the aztec horror
too
like what happens if you deep out in
mexico and you find out they're still
out there [ __ ] worried about shabolba
and the blood debt and all that
see you could have a badass horror like
that where you got modern mexicans doing
all that and maybe some of the in the
way the cartels kind of do do that
but
you can make that [ __ ] [ __ ] super
spooky it's
spookier probably if
they were kind of like educated
high-class mexican people
who believe this stuff a hundred percent
and they're doing all these ancient
rituals and yeah be like
cult yeah [ __ ] skeleton dead puppet
one kind of like that [ __ ] man yeah i'm
it's i'm blanking on the name but i'm
pretty sure i saw one similar to them if
you haven't seen midsummer that's
basically what it is it's just like the
white european version of that and
it's not
creepy on the surface it's creepy when
you think about it everything's white
and pretty and white clothing and
kind of pretty drawings and then you
look at the drawings it's a bear or a
person wrapped in a bear on fire you're
like what's that drawing mean and like
what's this oh you'll find out later
i'll find out later what all that [ __ ]
is you know it's weird is that a vagina
with someone cutting hair like what is
that yeah
is this grip sex what is that
it's sucking you know well that's what i
think was so great about that movie is
that it's really really difficult to
make something unsettling where the
whole thing takes place in the daytime
yeah okay louis seen that one he said
that's a very good movie because you
guys should who should watch the old way
it's a good movie about
bro
they're gonna use witchcraft yeah yeah
yeah i think you recommended that before
because i wrote it down um i watched the
trailer and that does actually look
really good so maybe we'll watch that
sometime this week and we'll talk about
it like on sunday or something no matt
didn't like uh mid-summer he's just
bored it's in its own genre
it's it's marginally it's folk horror
folk horror yeah which there's other
folk european folk horror and it goes to
it goes back to like wicker man
and
it's a different kind of [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] weird you know i wish speaking
of folk horror i wish somebody would
make a good movie
of thomas trion's novel harvest home
thomas trion was the same guy that wrote
the other you know the one yeah the
twins and everything like the other was
another good one um yeah so that was the
same novelist so this is like russian
folklore russian-american folklore
wasn't it wasn't she a russian
uh yeah i think she was actually yeah
she was a russian immigrant who taught
her russian or german i think i think
she was russian maybe well the actress i
taught her grandson how did like ashley
project type of deal
with the twins and everything into twins
yeah but so that the guy that wrote the
novel that that was based on thomas
trion who was also an actor by the way
um he wrote another novel called harvest
home which is actually one of my
favorite horror novels of all time and
they made a tv mini series of it like
back in the 70s or maybe the early 80s
and it was just
not that good
um
i don't know it had like a lot of big
stars in it but i just i don't know it
really kind of fell flat for me but it's
such a good book and i just really
really wish
that somebody especially like i said
because mid-summer was kind of like a
there was a big buzz about that and it's
like i thought there was going to be
like a folk horror resurgence and i was
kind of like hey somebody do harvest
home that would be [ __ ] rad although
it would probably make a better series
he was in that same hereditary
hereditary wasn't that same thing i did
not like that movie as much as i liked
midsummer it was too difficult to follow
i didn't like it as much how it flowed
jenny liked that one though a lot i
liked that a lot yeah that's actually
one of my favorite reasons out of the
two i liked mid-summer a lot but i also
really liked mid-summer this summer was
good and i like that kind of european
folk horror because it it kind of makes
sense
like you did this so we're going to do
that to you to cancel out what you did
and if you think about it you're like
okay yeah that would kind of be a
a solution but not real rational this is
magical thinking here we're going to
bury you upside down just your foot
coming up out out out of the out of the
out of the flower bed yeah just weird
[ __ ] like that that's what we do you
know
yeah
you did this so we're going to [ __ ]
cut your lungs out of the back here and
make you turn you into an eagle
and that'll cancel that out because you
pissed on the tree yeah the ancestor
tree just
you know it's time for you to die don't
piss on the ancestors that's your lesson
there you're old so you got to die go
ahead and jump
yeah
you've lived your life stop [ __ ] with
other people and even though yeah
and even though everyone was like no
they're into it they didn't come they
really didn't look like they were into
it they kind of looked like i don't know
about this yeah
couldn't you just like you know give us
an overdose of sleeping pills or
something you know what i mean why does
it have to be this way uh louis says
james wan is producing a salem's lot
reboot that better be good
although then then somebody said oh god
i'm sick stick a stupid sick of stephen
king already yeah uh the ritual is also
very good yes it is uh i really really
like the ritual you need to see you
should see uh blood on satan's claw
which was another like kind of british i
know it wasn't hammer or amicus either
i'm pretty sure maybe it was tygon just
like butch finder general if i'm not
mistaken
um
but that's that's kind of like a folk
horror type of [ __ ] too beowulf 18 says
stuff and retracts it all the time i
never see what he says unless other
people got him muted
yeah i'm not really sure because
sometimes yeah [ __ ] comes up and then he
says he takes it away
he doesn't want anybody like keeping
track of it
yeah he's trying to he's speaking
incognito he's coded
and justice for me said whoops and then
it like scrolled up have you ever seen
my amityville horror that's danny lutz
um that was that a documentary because i
kind of did we saw that right i think so
that sounds familiar you saw that
documentary of him yeah yeah yeah where
he was like talking about all kinds of
yeah i don't believe that dude
yeah i don't either but you know
anyway all right so um [ __ ] we better
get rolling there's only one documented
case that's in the [ __ ] sphere
that i pretty much know happened just
based upon what they said happened how
it was described and how it matched up
with things that i personally saw in um
in them in the mammoth mountain poultry
guys case that i was involved
and that was
like guy
guy lion place fair's book called this
house is haunted and i got a hardcover
copy of it there it's out of print or
well something somebody said is back in
print it is because they made um
the
second conjuring movie was based on
enfield the second or the third one i
can't remember yeah um at least the
edition i have i don't know if they've
added it or changed it i bought that
from like a library sale or something
i'm gonna say that that actually
happened because a lot of stuff that
they wrote some stuff that
only a person who could would have seen
it
would would have
you know again cops and newspaper people
saw it and it was just objects being
thrown out of nowhere
um
now some of the stuff was we heard
somebody say they were standing on the
other side of the street and they saw
her levitating in the window there was
only one witness and it wasn't a person
in the house it wasn't one of the main
witnesses there's a lot of other stuff
that gets thrown into the case
that probably didn't happen
uh the voice coming out of her mouth
they have that
recorded i think it's her subconscious
doing it's kind of like um
and i think she's also kind of [ __ ]
with people
um
and when you look at that case you can
see how
back in the middle ages if something
like that would happen they would have
said that she was possessed
well yeah there's a lot of crossover
there was she's possessed by a demon
look at the demons throwing things look
the demons speaking out of her
it's just a mixture of a
sight
recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis that
she can't control
acting out and [ __ ] um
kind of like um
epileptic kind of convulsions and
frustration you know she had a lot of
family problems this is kind of just a
bad house and a kind of a [ __ ] up
family and
you know and it was at the right there
were two girls in there going through
puberty and somehow
it causes that
but it's it's not supernatural it
doesn't have anything to do with the
dead
it's a fake ghost
although i think
they had access to things that happened
in the past somehow
yeah yeah who had lived there before
they although they could have picked
that up subconsciously somehow
who had lived there before and how they
died yeah they got that right
but maybe they heard that
and just repeated yeah that's the thing
it's like yeah there's no way of knowing
what they might have overheard someone
talking about or they might have read it
in the newspaper or something somebody
said to that person died in that chair i
mean there's just no way of knowing the
way that they couldn't have gotten
the information in some other way right
that's why that shit's so hard to prove
because
the only thing that only thing that you
could prove was the witnesses said
objects were being thrown and they were
being thrown from corners their people
weren't standing there
and things had just fallen from the
ceilings and furniture just being pushed
and the cops saw a [ __ ] chair just
lift up a few inches off the ground and
move over about a foot and drop nobody
was over in that side of the house
louie's talking about the uh san pedro
poltergeist said poltergeist case
investigated by some ucla professors i
think that's supposedly yeah yeah
i think i wrote about that in in uh my
book didn't i i think we did we do a
show about that
i don't know i'm pretty sure we did a
show about that i'd have to you have to
remind me of something in the case what
what did it actually do i can usually
remember by based on that was the one
wait was that the one that the entity
was based on
i kind of feel like that was the one
yeah and it didn't even actually
actually happen from when i understand
if it's the one that annoys me i mean
the movie like the end of the movie is
nothing like what actually happened but
um exaggerated a lot what was her name
carl moran or something like that yeah i
can't i can't remember what her real
name was i get because i get it confused
because i wrote about it but then we
talked about it the movie they're
paranormal because it's some kind of
quantum physics going on mind over
matter
i guess you might you don't mind it it
don't matter i don't know but [ __ ] uh
it's kind of like telekinesis of some
sort
oh happening
and it's just spontaneous and it happens
here every now and then depends on my
mood i wish i could control it
because i'd make all kinds of [ __ ]
money you crazy well yeah like i said
you could just like go get take a dollar
from every bank vault in america and put
it in your own account yeah just go to
vegas and force the dice to land
certainly you could do that too yeah
although like i said i'm lazy i would do
it for my own house just go
or you could just go on tour performing
that too but like again that sounds like
too much that sounds like too much
the military believed in it intelligence
agencies believed in it they spent money
on it they tried to weaponize it a lot
of the [ __ ] was classified
in my estimations they never they were
never able to get it to you to work
right
it wasn't really worth the trouble uh
with the exception possibly remote
viewing
and they don't re they evidently don't
rely on it
but they the remote viewers didn't get
some stuff right
but a satellite can get everything right
yeah so why rely on like some
hand wavy kind of well maybe that's kind
of what i drew kind of a vaguely
kind of looks like a mountain yeah you
know what i mean it's that kind of [ __ ]
all right so uh yeah we gotta we gotta
go because yeah we gotta go we movie
starts soon we're gonna miss it if we
sit here babbling all day all right so
we are going to the movie theater
right now like in half an hour and we're
gonna go see
malignant and then we will do a review
on that tomorrow
so thanks everybody for dropping by and
hanging out with us for a short time
today and we will see you guys again
tomorrow
bye